So now that we have a prototype, we're
moving to the validation stage, right?
>> That's right.
The validation stage answers
the hardest question in product design.
The hardest question
in product design is
how do you know if
your work is any good?
>> Okay, that's an important question.
>> [LAUGH] It's very important.
How we answer this question
has three different stages.
At Google we use something that
we call triple validation.
Just like in the beginning we looked
at a problem from the perspective of
business, technology,
and users, at the end
we want to validate the solution
from the same three touch points.
The most important opinion, and
the most important votes and
validation, is that of the users.
So the critical piece not to
miss is the opportunity to
test your prototype with your users.
We recommend sprinters and the sprint
lead recruit users from the very
beginning of the sprint, so they know
that, at the end, the users are coming.
>> Right.
>> And they have to prepare for it, and
else, all the efforts that they have
spent in prototyping could go to waste
because they don't actually know if this
is solving the needs the users have.
So meeting the users at the beginning
is useful to learn their needs, and
meeting them at the end is
crucial in order to test.
This type of test is called usability
test or Cognitive Walkthrough.
It allows you to put the products or
the early prototype in
the hands of a user and watch them
walkthrough all the different stages.
What do they like?
Where do they get stuck?
Do they understand
what the idea is about?
And it's important that they have and
they expressed earlier on.
>> Do I need to explain to
the user what he needs to do?
>> What we like to do in this stage
is kind of like it's based on one of
the ideas of writing, show, don't tell.
A great design prototype should
be able to stand on its own
without too much explaining.
Generally we'd like to set up the user
and say, imagine you're shopping for
a new product, or imagine you're
looking to write the review, and
now tell me what you see, and
now tell me what you're doing from here.
So we ask the users questions, and
ask them to imagine themselves
solving a specific scenario,
and we watch what they do.
We ask them questions to clarify, but
we're not trying to sell
the product to them.
One of the mistakes that
people make in this stage
is that they imagine this
is a marketing pitch and
they start explaining how awesome the
product is, or why they love the idea.
This is a useful approach if you're
trying to recruit that specific person
to buy your product and they might,
just because they're trying to be nice.
But this approach does not
answer the critical question,
is the product any good?
Like you force someone in person to
buy something is very different from
creating something that's popular,
and that works on its own.
>> That people love.
>> That's right [LAUGH].
>> And are users the only people I
want to get in front of this prototype?
>> Well, the user validation is
one of three points in the rapid
evaluation process.
The other two points involve
the business and the technology.
It's really useful to test with
the stakeholders of the team.
Is it still meeting the business goals?
Is it still answering the promises
that you made to investors, or
the goals that you have as a company?
And if yes, fantastic, and if no,
we need to go back to the drawing board.
More often than not, teams are aligned
with the business goals and
the stakeholders are happy
with the results.
But if you skip the validation,
they might not approve the design or
block it at a later stage.
So, having your quick check-in with the
stakeholders, even if they didn't attend
the entire sprint,
can be very useful at this stage.
>> Very cool.
>> Another piece that's important
here is doing a technical check.
A design solution that's beautiful but
no one can implement, it's only so
valuable.
So what we want to do is encourage teams
to check in with a technical staff.
Is this still going the right
direction in terms of feasibility?
And if this seems challenging,
let's clarify it.
What are the pieces here that seems like
they're going to take the longest and
how might we be able to point is
designing a way that's not creating
hurdles, and it's something that
we can test and deliver quickly?
>> Okay, so what I'm hearing is
we need to do three validations,
validate with users,
validate with business stakeholders, and
validate with technology people.
>> Yeah,
these validations can be rather quick.
A user test can be 20 to 30 minutes and
you can test with three or
four or five different people.
For most teams, you can even test with
one person, it's already a success.
The business validation can be
a five to ten minute discussion, or
longer if the issue is very problematic.
Or the technical validation can be
similarly short, five to ten minutes.
We're doing this as a best practice.
Sort of like covering a checklist to
make sure that all the possible ways in
which something can fail to deliver
after this point are addressed.
And there are also people
vouching to the solution,
which makes it easier
to deliver afterwards.
>> So what could go wrong in this stage?
>> That's a great question.
What could go wrong is that teams can
be overly confident in their own
solution and skip the user testing.
That is a common pattern that we see
with teams that are new to sprinting.
They think, well,
we can do the user testing later.
It is true that the user test can be
done separately from this print, but
that is a miss.
While the team is together and
they're fresh in the space
of all the prototyping, it is really
valuable to right away get feedback.
If you do the user test with
your whole team present and
right after the creation session, this
gives the need to write any research
documents and it keeps all
the ideas fresh in their minds.
That makes it that much more
likely that the products and
the problems will get
addressed in the next phase.
>> And what happens if they don't like
the solution, if the users hate it?
>> [LAUGH] Well,
if the users hate solution it's
a great opportunity to learn.
We try to be humble with our designs.
After all, we only spend two
to five days working on them.
We hope that the life of the company
will be much longer than that, so
those two to five days were
valuable if you learn something.
So if the users don't like something,
it's a great time to
seek to understand again.
So we go back to the first way of
thinking, which was let's understand.
What is it that they don't like,
is there something that
could be solved better?
Asking questions and
probing deeper into the things that
users don't like is great opportunity.
The best time to learn if
the users don't like something
is right after you have created
the prototype, into the five days.
And not after you spend two years of
your life telling everyone you love and
maxing out your credit card
[LAUGH] this is a great idea.
>> So in this stage,
we take the users, we let them play with
the prototype, and we listen to them.
>> That's right.